voilà ça c'est un ballet celles
indispensables accessoires pour faire du
jazz car ici au el camino a quand il y
aura le mini fest dès ce soir
jusqu'à quand que samedi alors nicolas
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir écouter ici
même dans ce joli el camino au jazz
hervé soir d'une erreur par soit réglé
par an il ya du jazz swing et du jazz
plus moderne qui a des chanteuses des
pianistes des saxophonistes des élèves
du compte les actions où il ya plein de
choses
donc vous vous venez du quant aux
actions j'enseigne aux contres les
actions voilà un parce que c'est un
endroit on peut le rappeler où se passe
énormément de choses et surtout on
apprend à jouer du jazz
c'est l'enseignement amateurs mais et
des orchestres des cours d'instruments
tous à la rentrée c'est la semaine
prochaine guerre
ils peuvent voir jusqu'au bout de la
nuit
jusqu aux bonnes affaires avec les
anciens on va dire mardi si les anciens
en fait ils sont toujours là ils sont là
ils s'accrochent c'est de
l'improvisation c'est du jazz
et c'est à partir de ce soir jusqu'à
samedi au el camino à caen deux concerts
par soir c'est combien ces 6 et 10 euros
6 et 10 euros pour le mini fest 11e
édition 11e venez nombreux
toi jacques c'est show johnny tu attends
pour faire son show je suis le dernier
de de six enfants est donc en fait c'est
vrai que quand ma mère a accouché
c'était c'était bien mais bien balisé y
avait des néons les sorties etc
enfin j'ai quand-même j'arrive quand
même dans une famille où il ya le poids
de la maladie
mon frère aîné mort d'une leucémie
visiblement j'ai dû être conçue sur le
tard parce que il mes parents avaient 42
43 ans un peu pour amener du voyez-vous
du bonheur dans une famille s'était déjà
bon c'était des historiens des
historiens scientifiques au plus en plus
des protestants
quelle liste donc albini ça n'a rien à
voir là qu'avec la maladie d'alain juppé
n'en calvini c'est donc le le courant
des protestants très austère et c'est
donc tout de suite quand je suis sorti
j'ai senti qu'il fallait quand même que
je fasse un peu rire quoi ça c'est ma
mon arbre qui cache la forêt je me cache
derrière ce truc là pour pouvoir monter
sur scène parce que le finalement la
comédie c'était un petit peu mon rêve
depuis quand même vraiment un comédien
raté qui dessine sur scène parce que
voilà pour expliquer aux gens comment ça
marche parce que quand vous commencez à
faire des dessins sur scène c'est c'est
très très mauvais donc c'est quand même
mal barré chaunu vous vous rêvez d'une
carrière uniquement d'acteurs en
oubliant le dessin je crois pas parce
qu'il ya d'abord des gens bien meilleur
que moi je veux regarder cette
originalité
en tout cas la faire connaître et
saint lô me permet de faire connaître
cette originalité qu'elle arrive à un
moment de l'histoire kaka centre on a eu
des attentats de charlie on a eu le
bataclan un caricaturiste qui monte sur
scène paradoxalement peut-être que ça a
un sens voilà pendant très très
longtemps je me suis dit on va partir
aux vacances au maroc parce que mon père
avait une 504 cette voiture a été
extraordinaire elle était blanche elle
était entièrement entièrement en
dentelle d'alençon le bas de caisse
quand on est très très timide hyper
timide et très introverti si on veut se
sortir de cette opinion de ce trou il
faut qu'on trouve le moyen de d'en faire
des caisses
parce que sinon ben l'ascenseur il nous
laisse dans la mine
voilà la 504 donc on n'est jamais parti
au maroc on allait chaque été sur la
côte de nacre
voilà moins quinze lots à des cabines de
plage voilà c'est le drame de ma vie je
ne suis jamais allé au maroc mais mon
père avec 504 merci emmanuel mais vous
êtes je crois en plateau ce soir avec
laurent marvyle laurence et oui c'est à
vous mais bien sûr ils savent exactement
à celle avatar 2 des manuels c'est pas
le vrai je vais vérifier